the first thing is it is what it is I'm
going to show you the kind of question
where the culprit is pointing at right
here I'm sort of trying to just save
time and then we'll have a look at the
accident and then we're going to move
back and get it multiple servers okay
that'll be um that will be this morning
and then in period six I think it means
we're going to carry on two identities
so here is the question we were looking
at now I'm trying to gain the distinct
advantage good morning if I tell you
right away that this question has to do
republic's what you do here or rather
you can take advantage of comics when
you read here right off the map to same
you travel time okay so how am i going
to use it in the light of this
polynomial
and this way you're a kind of complex
group and they're all
fantastic say it's to get people
together together without any excellent
okay good good
so just rewind a little bit the two
pieces of information on you are I know
our number one or real coefficients
number two I have one of the roots and
it is compact right well having all the
roots from each context okay but
importantly it has a magic pot so then
well I'm going to state by the complex
conjugate read through and I'm going to
encourage you to write this even though
it is pretty long I don't think it's I
don't see see auntie is accepting the
wave DMT is so I'm going to say comics
under root theorem just because I don't
want the code you get to just come out
of their way right so by this theorem
since and this is way more detail in
correlate I'll try to be mathematically
sound as well as providing the right
answer since years ed has real
coefficients
that means if I just take the conjugate
of this brother
okay now this is great for two reasons
number one thinking back to not the free
trade agreement the fundamental theorem
algebra this is a polynomial of degree 3
which means it has how many complex
roots through example 2 3 right no if
you are no more so I've already got two
of them I only need to find the last one
that will be useful to be missing so now
that I know these two that tells me
something about the factorization right
so I can say therefore the area is equal
to I've got that - this is that - that
and then I'm going to have some question
along the end ok so I'm gonna have just
watch out your brackets inside to you
I'm gonna write an essay - yes ziad -
this
okay just like I care I care but what
give me anything useful before they'll
tell me is zero accordance in fact to do
very much like it will just pop in and
say yeah it's right that's that's all in
something okay so there's the first two
factors that I already know now I don't
know what the other factor is I'm just
going to call it to you partly because I
already have super questions okay
because having divided by this right now
have a look at this what I want to try
to get to is well what's the final
factor because I want a linear
factorization is likely to degree 3 over
1 - that's the third one okay before I
get there you can see one of the great
things about in fact a big complex
fudging it is that these guys are going
to simplify up really really easy okay
now before you launch into doing three
terms x three term for any other minor
damage purple you'll see black simply to
Diedra I want you to remember some of
the properties of these complex
conjugates right so maybe just left on
the side here
if you have Z minus alpha n 0 minus
alpha bar okay like this for a second
just think about how it's going to
expand just as a community
just thinking out how it's going to
expand as a as if my good people okay
what are we going to get you're gonna
get it squared out the front
- -
- let's find another your kitchen it's
gonna be alcohol
wait just think about your equipment to
get out right so you might say opposite
it's gonna be also an alpha Bob said
right and then what's trailing on the
end it just comes from the closet -
right which is plus alpha alpha Bob is
that okay but remember what alpha at
alpha bar are and how they relate to
each other but they are complex
conjugates so therefore we can add them
together together the imaginary parts
are going to disappear or they get a
cancer that right so in fact all you're
going to get is two blocks off the real
part of alpha do you agree with that
okay what happens when we multiply them
look at them it's difference of squares
but because of the eyes that come in
ends up in the summer sweaters right so
fact this plant is going to become the
real part of alpha square and the
imaginary part of alpha square okay does
that make sense and that's going to
dramatically make this simpler by every
time we use the comic quadrivium
we're gonna get complex conjugates so
rather than multiply this whole thing
out it's a disaster
you're asking for silly errors to
pre-clear I'm just going to take
advantage of these results so for
instance I'm gonna get it quadratic as
and I'm never worried you take away now
let's double the real pot off-mike
chosen alpha double the real pot is just
full gee that was a lot simpler than
trying to do we have three terms of into
this into this and then I'm going to add
on add on the real squared and the
imaginary square that looks like four
and nine to me
whoa just like that all right this is
like one of your just so easy to work
okay that look right yeah okay now at
this point there are one of two things
that we can do there are two parts to
finish out the question and find out
what these qs8 anyone suggests to me one
of the positive 8
okay so the first method is the first
method is and I need to actually rewind
women with it right the first minister
recognizer came this must be a linear
factor right it must be with you because
I've already got degree 2 here this has
to Mars planet degree 3 so this must be
degree 1 it's not only linear hug I also
know it's a monic how do I know it's one
this is Manik Manik must be money okay
so 13 Manik and linear which means that
I can write this in this form then - I
read the sign
yes
yes very good he would have it would
have yes that's right
so in order to tie off like you should
use how you're up against is but complex
ones are it here right
I know that either you're going to have
budgets or you're gonna have complex
coefficients okay and I can't come
either those right because I'm going to
use two methods of living on one left
and I don't have any complex
coefficients to get there so that's nice
I don't necessarily need to state that
but it's popular so I guess I'm gonna
safe yeah but you know I'll actually
gonna write P Z over here on the left
right it's actually this
now what makyo is just mentioned it is
essentially comparison of coefficients
right essentially concoctions we're
trying to say that what if this ends up
being it was our original polynomial
right but if you look closely for
instance you can see there's only a
symbols that you to turn right there's
only one way out of this expansion just
get it a few turns out of this since
we're and that's it there's no other
combination of these terms that we keep
using cube in exactly the same way
there's only one combination of terms
that will give you this constant over
here which combination it's going to be
it's plus right just plus 30 and this -
beat up do you agree with that so that's
one way of saying it another way of
saying it which I kind of prefer because
that's like I'd rather write about I can
just evaluate T of zero that's another
way of getting to the constant term
that's take away all of the Z or the
variable that if I evaluate P of 0 here
is goes 0 0 0 - 39 and then this guy
becomes well 0 0 13
if x 0 mines vo-tech like so so there
you go you've got your value there and
you can bring that back to the center